while it's tough for us in this heat
think about what it can do to your cars
let's throw that up
jeremy j ford has some important
maintenance tips to keep you being from
being stuck on the side of the
[Music]
road warmer temperatures can lead to
major car problems from batteries to
tire pressures and even air conditioning
systems you may want to get your car
serviced before you're left stranded
as if general wear and tear on your
vehicle isn't enough the summer heat can
also cause major damage to your car that
can be prevented if caught early i spoke
with auto parts specialist mario
maldonado about ways you can prevent car
failure first you want to inspect your
radiator hoses and belts
because belts do happen to pop
and
deteriorate with the heat radiator hoses
do go bad with age
not replacing them another thing we
could do is inspect all your battery
make sure all your fluids are top off
like your antifreeze because that's one
cause that will cause your vehicle to
overheat in the summertime
maldonado also recommends replacing your
battery every two years getting your
electrical system checked and protecting
your interior with tint or a sun shade
to keep it cool
jeremy j ford live local now